تطبيق جديد يلحف الافق قد يغزو العالم
الافتراضي فبعد اكثر من اربع سنوات من
غياب مؤسسي خدمه انستغرام عن الساحه عدم
مجددا مع تطبيق جديد يوصف بانه سيكون
التيك توك الاخبر الحديث هنا لكافنسيستروم
ومايك بريكر اللذين اعلن اطلاقا تطبيق هنا
الجديد ارتيك الذي سيقدم موجزا اخباريا
قائما على احدث تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
في منشور على انستغرام
يعملان مع فريق موهوب منذ اكثر من عام على
اطلاقه هذا التطبيق واضاف انهم بداوا
اتاحت التطبيق للمستخدمين تدريجيا كما من
الممكن الان لاي شخص الانضمام الى قائمه
انتظار لتجربه التطبيق فماذا يميز هذا
التطبيق الجديد
بخلاف انستغرام يركز التطبيق الجديد
بالدرجه الاولى على المقالات بدلا من
الصور حيث يقدم ارتفاعات توصيات بالمحتوى
بناء على الاهتمامات وسيعرض الموجز
الرئيسي للتطبيق الجديد المقالات الشائعه
من المؤسسات الاعلاميه الكبرى بالاضافه
الى المدونات الاخرى حسب تفضيلات المستخدم
ووفقا لما ذكره موقع بلاتفورمر الذي كان
اول من كشف عن اطلاق هذا التطبيق فانه
سيسمح بالمناقشه مع الاصدقاء ووصف الموقع
تطبيق الجديد بانه تيك توك للنصوص وربما
يشكل خطرا مفاجئا على تويتر وتساعد ميزات
التطبيق المستخدمين على الحصول على
الاخبار بشكل موجز مع الحفاظ على سرعه
التداول مقاطع الفيديو مثل تطبيق تيك توك